so listen I don't pretend to know what's
going to happen in November with the
presidential election Donald Trump may
well get himself reelected we did a
story today about how Trump might try to
use a vaccine October Surprise to get
himself reelected anything could happen
and all of the polling could reverse by
November but we continue to see polling
signals that four and a half months out
from the election we can't ignore them
and many of them are state polls the
national polls are interesting to look
at and we looked at that earlier when we
look at a place like Arkansas the latest
poll out of very read Arkansas is
stunning Donald Trump is leading Joe
Biden in Arkansas by only 247 to 45 now
understand that in 2016
Donald Trump won Arkansas by 27 Trump
won by 27 in 2016 in 2012 Mitt Romney
beat Barack Obama in Arkansas by 24 in
2008 John McCain defeated Barack Obama
by 20 in Arkansas even if the five
percent who are currently supporting a
third party candidate and the three
percent who were currently unsure all go
to trump between now and November in
Arkansas Trump would win Arkansas by
only 10 this would be the smallest
margin of victory for a Republican in
Arkansas I don't even know for how long
and it would signal some insane
possibilities for November also
important in looking at the internals of
this Arkansas poll are that more people
disapprove of Trump than the number that
approve this is a very red state so to
see the approval numbers turn against
Trump in Arkansas is not a good sign for
him Senator Tom cotton a Republican
whack-job from Arkansas also is
underwater he has disapproval of 47
approval of 44 so he's minus 3 there and
where this is coming from is
independence in Arkansas Arkansas has
more Republicans than Democrats as you
probably imagine the Democrats are
mostly not voting for Trump the
Republicans mostly are voting for Trump
right now independence in our
can saw are leaning towards Joe Biden by
six points and so that may well be the
group so to speak that is going to cause
Trump some trouble now do I think
Trump's going to lose Arkansas no I
don't think he's going to lose Arkansas
is it likely that if the numbers stay
this tight Trump will have to spend some
money in Arkansas yeah it does become
likely and that's already a victory
because any dollar Trump has to spend in
Arkansas is a dollar he may not be
spending somewhere else and if it is
even remotely this close it is going to
be a real problem for Donald Trump and
this is why remember every single one of
us has to operate as if Trump could win
any state Trump seemingly could lose
some traditionally Republican states but
we also have to understand that we all
must vote every single one of us he
won't be competitive in California he
won't be competitive in Massachusetts
but why take a chance why take a chance
when the risk is four more years four
more years of Trump four more years of
environmental destruction four more
years of being the laughingstock of the
world four more years of Supreme Court
choices and all of the things that we
have been warning about so very bad
numbers for Trump they won't change my
behavior when it comes to voting and
they shouldn't change yours either